en mariupol el alto el fuego decretado
por los rusos no se cumplió el batallón
de azov denuncia sangrientos
enfrentamientos y acusó a moscú de
atacar a los civiles pero a pesar de los
combates el viernes se inició una nueva
evacuación de al menos 23 civiles y
hoy ha continuado la operación de
rescate de mariupol con la ayuda de la
onu y el comité internacional de la cruz
roja la gente está de camino a una zona
segura en total más de 150 personas de
'las hostal y más de 300 personas de
mariupol y sus suburbios han sido
evacuadas a través del corredor
humanitario esta semana comentaron el
corredor el presidente ucraniano también
acusa a los rusos de seguir bombardeando
la zona mientras que el kremlin lo niega
nuestro presidente y comandante supremo
el presidente putin ha dado públicamente
la orden de no lanzar un asalto a la
planta de asoex tal no se ha dado
ninguna otra orden
el jueves por la noche vladimir putin
dijo que el ejército ruso seguía
preparado para garantizar la evacuación
de los civiles al parecer todavía hay
200 refugiados en el complejo atrapados
entre los combates ucranianos tras más
de dos meses de asedio e intensos
bombardeos mariupol está casi
completamente destruida el presidente
volodymyr selenski dijo que sería
necesaria una versión moderna del plan
marshall para reconstruir la ciudad así
como todas las demás devastadas por la
guerra